today you were probably gonna do
something that was in my opinion little
overdue and have a class about one of
the best chess players of all time
Alexander alia it's called a yo Keem and
you will say Alekhine okay whatever you
want to pronounce it I find him to be
one of the more original players of all
time
very exciting chess player sometimes he
was really like devil-may-care
happy-go-lucky in the opening as you
will see at least once or twice here
today and nonetheless he was very
original he's thinking and very very
impressive what we're gonna do is we're
gonna see two different positions where
I hope that that can prove to you that
the ordinary player would have chosen
one route but he chose a completely
different route and then we will see two
games where he just shows his mastery in
planning so let's start with this
example from his game against Akiva
Rubinstein the same the same one with it
we saw in the previous lecture that was
not recorded in that game Akiva
Rubinstein beat someone very
impressively we see in a position that
looks a little funny like when I'm
looking in this position it looks to me
like I want to hit myself in the back of
the head so the things will straighten
out normally you have this position
where like this knife might be here and
this Bishop might be on f4 if the knight
is here in the bishop here then I have a
semi-normal position but something when
bizarre and the bishop is on a very
strange square and the knight on g6
really strange right so now it's right
to move now I will bet anyone when I say
original player and playing thinking out
of the box then of course it's much
harder to solve or think of the moves
but when I showed this position to my
students without any ceremonies without
any announcements and I asked him okay
why to move what would you play here so
they think and I don't care if they are
1200 or 2200 they look at this position
and they come up with different plans
and the plans they come up with usually
range between Lucchesi one trying to
take advantage of the unprotected knight
on c6
okay not a tragic move porn a three
sometimes you hear that they say oh the
bishop on f8 might want to pin my knight
on on before I don't agree but it's a
move and of course the main suggestion
the one that gets the most point and I
bet that some of you might be thinking
is g3 Bishop g2 castles because you have
to move the city move Bishop on e3 it's
gonna be a hassle
some people get evolved and say well how
about if I play Bishop g5 move it from
an odd spot if the Queen moves I'll play
III if the bishop goes to e7 are trade
bishops then III Bishop d3 castles and
life is not so bad so all of these moves
may make some sense listen you can't say
oh you just suggested an absurd move now
everything is just really cool but a
European in this position decided to
play a little differently and notice the
plan that he plays I'm gonna show you
how it's done but it's really nice to
see and some sort of a how to put it
some sort of a symphony like it's a when
is that in harmonious in harmony of a
bunch of moves together however he
played H pork straight up immediately
saying hey the knight on g6 is a funny
Knight and I'm going to take advantage
of it also I have he says to himself I
have chance to take advantage of the
dark squares and I'm gonna make the
maximum okay he's the poet is not
exactly a partner he said Akiva
Rubenstein is a grand master level
player so he plays Bishop d6 he realizes
that in one second I'm gonna go h5 and
this night is gonna have to go back
blocking my bishop how or else I'm gonna
develop this Bishop later who knows of
course I moved like h5 it's just gonna
bring a smile to the face because it's
very easy for me to defend h4 by playing
g3 at the right moment but h5 is gonna
be a real target at some at some moment
like even if you let's see if you play
h5 and I'm gonna play even a move like
Bishop g5 whether we trade bishops or
not at some point later I'm gonna play
III my light will move maybe to e5 or g5
in my queen especially with a bishop on
me to this point is gonna suffer a lot
and of course you won't be able to
cancel like a normal person so he played
Bishop d6 I moved it makes sense
h5 we continue with our plan forward
okay 97 what else can we suggest again
the most normal of moves and that point
is not done yet the aged Pony Express
advantage advances to 86 of course I'm
just threatening h2 g7 if you take and I
take that's awesome
so he plays g6 so in the trait within
three moves we are seeing a beautiful
transformation the black King said looks
a little like the dark squares are not
happy and white continues in the same
spirit Bishop g5 that bishop that took
really clumsy on e3 is now conquering
another beautiful diagonal beautiful
play by Ali okay now my intention is to
put it on f6 and it's going to be hard
to stop
so castles sooner or later you have to
if you played it on the moving I played
Bishop f6 attacking your rook
you're not gonna move your rock right
you have to cancel so castles Bishop f6
what a beautiful plan by White's so
original out of nowhere a position
disliked dormant and sleepy most players
would have played g3 or rook c1 never to
see this game again unless you find it
in some old notebook and this game look
what look what the game continues a lot
of a sudden black becomes really nervous
because he thinks wait a minute I'm not
gonna get ephod easily at all
even if I do all my positions gonna be
weak what am I gonna do about Bishop c8
I don't know what am I gonna develop
that so he is playing b5 trying to get
some initiative on the Queen's ax and
again I'll say it one more time remember
who is playing with the black pieces a
world-class player one of the strongest
of the era and watch how he's struggling
against our Jochen I'm not saying this
is a great loo because it's create noone
creating new weaknesses and watch how
beautifully he takes advantage of them
but it's really it's already the
position is a little unpleasant to play
I'm not saying it's lost but it's
already becoming a bit uncomfortable
so b5 III obviously Bishop d7 again
Bishop b7 makes even less sense because
you're just biting on bread just looking
at your pawns here at least maybe have
some hope later on moving to the Queen
side so Bishop d3 the last minor goes
into the game rook c8 those last moves I
think they are very trivial I think that
there's just any club players might have
chosen them as well now a 4 comes
excellent immediately tickling the poem
b5 creating a crisis now what to do of
course black doesn't want to take
because then pony 6 is just dead and
then point a 4 is gonna die right after
it basically losing a pawn taking you
can't protect it enough there's no way
to protect it enough times because it's
already attacked three times defendant
only once
so what on one heck are we gonna do it's
gotta advance it and he does b4 was
played now it's our turn what are we
gonna do with the knight again this is
what we talked about really good
planning in chess
take your knight in an immediate
imaginary hand and think what is my
final destination for it where am I
going to end up with this time what
we're gonna do with this night watch
what he does 92 yeah Dutton itself is
not very hard but do you see the final
stop
let's see Queen b6 and now Knight c1
some of you might say wait a minute this
night is going to f/4 or g3 now no this
is at that end I'm not gonna make this
King right now but the week the Queen
side is rich with weaknesses so 91 now
the knight wants to land on b3 I can
tell you but of course I'm cheating
because I've seen this game all the way
to its end so it's very miserable Antrim
black if I was black here I would play
b3 you want to take my pawn take my pawn
and joy will do whatever do your worst
I want to give you the pawn just to have
some breathing space once the white
light gets to b3 without the pawn
advancing their black is having
no fun whatsoever so I would have played
b3 still it's a very pleasant choice but
I can either take or not take you know
pick up the right time do whatever I
want beautiful position for white so
anyways rooks e7 trying to double rooks
on the C file 90 p3 beautiful
95 again the night on b3 is becoming
very pastiche very annoying for example
one idea have is to play a5 myself if I
go 85 then guess what the poor lady is
going to have to defend this babysit
this pawn forever I have a bishop here
attacking it if I'm going to get a 5 in
and the Queen moves then I'm gonna go
Queen e2 then black black is gonna have
to dedicate lots of pieces to defending
that weakness forever
very poor position so he doesn't want to
allow it and he also wants to trade
Knight and white immediately plays based
on the tactics Knight g5 may be
Rubinstein thought the document was
impossible in this maneuvering maybe he
miscalculated but now he's facing a
crisis very very bad now what to do in
the game he played Knight c4 if you
would have taken it and I take it Queen
takes of course you cannot take with the
rope United me 7 is hanging if you take
it I'm gonna go Bishop d4 you have a
very easy move because it's your only
one Queen Queen to c6 if you go Queen d6
I'm gonna go here bye-bye exchange and
I'm killing you on the C file so he had
to play Queen c6 and now 95 my g4 game
over threatening Bishop e5 threatening
Knight f6 threatening Bishop g7 and 9 f6
and this dark squares just looks like
some Swiss cheese right completely
game over yeah so very difficult
situation so night on c5 he has to
swallow dot frog and tolerate it he
tries Knight c4
again trying to get some counterplay
however this is already calculated first
of all we eliminate that little thing no
need to have that must take back and he
played the move 95 not bad but maybe
they move 94 would have been even more
annoying because now you're not moving
almost anything like really bad like one
idea have 9 takes d6
Queen takes d6 the aforementioned Bishop
e5 winning the material and great a
second idea yeah Bishop to g7 attacking
the rook if the rook wants to move
Knight f6 check and for those of you
play bug house this is a very familiar
situation the bug house is in the backup
cheering yes absolutely hard hard to not
think about it in the back in baghouse
terms because how often do you see point
eight six Bishop g7 and the night coming
to f6 so this would have been an even
better move probably after the take to
go 94 he plays 95 not exactly a losing
move if he and if you use an
understatement beautiful just tremendous
now the bishop on d7 is threatened
everything everything is threatened pawn
c4 is threatened and again if I get to
take on c4 it's like a domino takes
takes Bishop e5 takes attack everything
falls apart
so he played Bishop takes in five very
reluctantly Bishop takes me seven
clearly the best move Bishop d6 yeah
what else already he is in real deep
trouble if he goes rook e8 to try to
save his exchange then probably taking
bishop here and something something is
gonna fall I don't know if this is the
only plan but this is one good plan so
miserable position really a terrible
position he decides to suffer this way
but after takes takes takes takes a5
Queen f3 I often had no problems winning
the ending for the record we'll see the
rest of the game
rook d5 rook c1 Queen moves away
the pawn fell okay
one trick if rook takes c3 Bishop before
is winning but no here
kingi to not notice how solid the white
position is is up and exchange the King
feels totally safe on the live squares
white as black has nothing to attack the
light squares Queen here now five rook
p1 already threatening sacrifices the
Queen moves Queen C for improving
again just simple plays just beautiful
simple play creating a passed pawn and
pushing it and pushing it and this was I
don't know if that was a joke or a
serious move but checkmate
because after here the volume is offered
from the machine says checkmate
so beautiful performance again from a
starting position that looks so naive so
much so simple he managed to create
something that makes a mess out of it
gets an advantage and wins now to our
second game our second position now if
you thought that the first one was
really simple this is one heck of a mess
yeah I think I showed it somebody in
this class in one of our lessons this
position really really a master position
take a good look I'll let you adjust to
it because what is going on it's white
to move and it looks like he can take a
whole piece which is really great and
however he has some problems he has some
real serious issues mainly the blocking
is canceled and the White King is stuck
in the center and black is threatening
the famous mousetrap of sheep for
dropping this bishop so yeah a very very
difficult situation what to do with
white let's check some of the
possibilities and see how they just
don't work out for example say you take
this guy then I'm gonna go rook e8 check
good luck with what you wanna do think
somewhere I don't know King f2 maybe
okay f1 okay the suggestion is king of
wanna do king of one
and then c4 so basically black is
getting his piece back and it's very
easy to understand in this position how
the bishop on b7 is going to be a
monster Bishop on the long diagonal
well this bishop on c1 is like an orphan
still trying to find some some pasture
to operate on so this from White's point
of view is just complete gloom I think
the computer says something like minus
one or two or something like really bad
so that's out maybe we can play
something like how about c4 looks like a
really nice move preventing the
mousetrap and still attacking the knight
but in this position black has a monster
move a real beautiful response again
taking advantage of the king in the
center d5 what a shot
just to me this is like a real beautiful
move now again just threatening to chop
the bishop if you take the knight same
story rook check the poor King has to
move pawn takes pawn I'm regaining my
piece and again I'm going to end up with
the awesome light square bishop against
this thing on c1 that is just a little
bit lost that's out okay other tries
Bishop d5 trying to save the bishop by
moving it but then again black has a
very simple answer takes getting rid of
the attack piece takes attacking the
rook and now simply Queen b6 a beautiful
developing move with the idea of playing
Bishop b7 on the long diagonal what a
monster position this bishop is just
murder
it's a murderous Bishop and this Bishop
is just very clumsy of course if you
take the rook just Bishop e7 and you're
gonna have to give up your queen for the
other rock but then the Queen and the
bishop on the long diagonal is just no
match for those rooks who are just not
in the game there are no open files for
them right now and they're not even
close to open files so of course the
Queen is ten times better than the rocks
that is that variation is also out and
lastly if castles trying to keep the
King safe then after c4 pawn takes Queen
take
the bishop is still lost on b3 so we
didn't lose a piece we're gonna get it
back and for the umpteenth time
eventually after the rook moves or
whatever the bishop is gonna come to the
diagonal and again this Bishop is much
better than c1 this position is not
looking very fun for white right again
typical for aliens happy-go-lucky style
in the opening what did you watch what
he what he met watch the imagination he
plays the move black plays the move and
it looks like he just made matters worse
but actually no look what's up a4 it
could play a 4 but imagine if I go
something like c4 you move your Bishop
and I move my knight at some point I
mean really really bad and again
remember I can play Bishop to b7 at any
moment the king in the center is just
dying what he does is just unfathomable
I think if I give you lots of guesses
anybody who hasn't seen the game is
gonna have a really hard time so he
plays Bishop III okay I move that makes
sense now it's not so simple to play a
move like c4 because a I'm gonna take
your rook on f8 the one that was hoping
to check then I'm gonna pick the knight
on f6 right so if c4 I can just take
here then take here that's great
so that takes care of that on the other
hand I'm developing my Bishop and I'm
ready to take your pawn for free
hearing the rook and I'm ready to cancel
and I'm ready to take this Knight later
on so at first you're saying wow white
found the solution but black plays Queen
a5 now he's attacking that Bishop and if
that Bishop was hoping to take the pawn
on c5 that's out because I'm gonna go
Queen takes c3 for King King and Bishop
bye-bye Bishop all of a sudden it looks
that the boy bad position I've been
aggravated like it became even worse
than before
the Grandmaster wanted to show his I
thought you never seen that okay
you do well he didn't play it no he
played exclam excellent I mean this is
just fantastic
now again black history is stuck because
having said a he must say B if you don't
take the bishop I'm just gonna take on
c5 and otherwise have no worries again
there's no c4 and I'm threatening you
Knight trust me I'm gonna take you
knight on f6 be sure of that so he is
kind of rolling with the punches now he
took here Y took here and black heads
one move in this position he has an only
move in this position because guess what
I'm about to go Queen defy lesson in
geometry Queen d5 attacking the rook if
you do something about the rook I'm
gonna go Queen g5 and you can have a
little a bit of a headache of what to do
about the mate here so fantastic what
does he do he plays c4 Queen d5 as
promised and now Queen a5 and black
definitely counted on this move again
this is reka bretty a famous player and
composer he's not a part sir he knows
what he's doing and he may be counted on
this move to save himself however
Alexander saw and examine all European
saw a little further what is the purpose
of this move now if Queen g5 water break
if Queen g5 threatening what seemingly
is an unavoidable mate black is commonly
playing check King H one Queen takes f6
and white can just go to lunch because
he is busting alternatively if you take
my rook I have another idea I'm gonna go
Queen b6 Chuck King h1 and if you
remember from previous variations Bishop
e7 trapping the Queen forcing you to
give the Queen for the rock after which
again my bishop on the long diagonal
this Bishop is dead and I'm happier than
anything so what to do now is white now
it looks like white is a bit stuck
because this Bishop here well how to say
gently is in trouble he plays
f 2 XG 7 a very intelligent move now you
can already understand that well the
King is a bit unsafe and in the
variations mentioned before for example
Queen takes a 8 Queen b6 check King H 1
Bishop e7 is not that good anymore
because F 8 has a bit of an issue so
Queen b6 check that's necessary King H 1
King take G 7 eliminating the point of
course the check was important so
there's not going to be any Queen checks
and surprises now the Queen can block
now what to do again every move seems
like black is just refuting White's very
desperate and heroic attempt not to lose
his bishop now a Leo can simply played
after good calculations Bishop takes e4
the bishop is coming out so rudely how
by just taking that point now it becomes
evident he just didn't take the bishop
he played Bishop e7 the game ended in a
draw we're gonna go over this very very
quickly just for the record but the
point was that if pawn takes Bishop I
can now take here Bishop d7
and now the B file is already open
because I sacked my Bishop bish Brooke
b1 take my queen I'll take your queen
Saeki queen for a rock and I'm gonna set
my queen for a rock with Chuck and in
old situation black is just very unhappy
he's down in exchange for nothing so he
knew not to take the bishop but then of
course the bishop on c4 is just alive
after Bishop e7 he played Chuck queen
blocks Bishop d3 and white survived this
the game ended in a draw but not before
black had to work a little bit
there was a rock ending the talent in
the draw that's not so interesting and I
want to make sure that we show you two
more things that I want to show but
again if you look at this starting
position it looks like a good move seems
like resigning here you know what at
least planning to resign and instead he
makes the move and all of a sudden black
has to go through a bunch of hurdles
they go to a pond down ending that he
managed to hold okay
now we will see a whole game as opposed
to a position and he is playing here a
very formidable opponent one of the best
American players of all time
known as the American Foxx frank
marshall anybody that knows the marshal
gambit the marshal attack is that's his
invention very aggressive player always
hunting for the king always attacking
always initiative and watch what he does
to him now the opening is a bit funny
because both players are playing very
provocative and both were not very well
known for good opening play but then
watch the originality of the plan in the
early middle game so d4 d5
c4 okay already and move to black plays
a move that's considered to be dubious
because you want to do something with
your point in do you accept the gambit
or if not you hold the gambit with the
pawn so you insist on having a pawn on
d5 whenever it's traded okay here he
took takes and now again white play the
move that's not the best of course the
move that looks the best is efore and
that's what he played but now you need
to play the move Knight f3 and I'll
explain in a second why the move Knight
f3 simply wins the tempo you place a
move like this some games with Knight f3
e6 then II for United's to move again if
after 9 f3 you will play a move like
let's say Bishop f5 try to stop before
then I'm going to go here very
unpleasant already I'm tickling the pole
on b7 gaining a good temper with my
queen
urging you to provoke a weakness and
it's very unpleasant so white gains a
temple regardless but in the game he
played a bit too casually with E 4 9 f6
now we have a position that's kind of
very similar from the Queens gambit
accepted the motifs I'm intending to
attack the pawn on e5 when you push a 5
already well if you play e5 Knight d5
it's just like I've conquered the b5
square just tacking this period of the
variation in the Queens gambit accepted
if you play Knight c3 I'm gonna go a 5
immediately strike if you go now
d5 Bishop c5 is just great for black and
if you accept the pawn
Queen D 1 and now if Knight XD 1 Knight
takes e4 ok that's just an even trade
King takes D one night g4 and I'm
attacking the pawn on f2 and I'm
attacking the pawn on d5 regaining my
pawn white lost the right to castle yeah
not great so you play Bishop d3 and very
true to nature 'if I've excellent the
best answer the most aggressive answer
if you don't do that I'm just gonna play
Knight f3 Knight c3 Bishop f4 castle and
white as a center that just roams so
this is a great shot you must accept it
if you go d5 again Bishop c5 black he's
just developing freely that's great so
takes Knight to g4 Lucky's regaining the
pawn with a totally fine position Knight
f3 have to defend the pawn 96 again
setting a little bit of a trap in this
position and in this position after some
thinking are you having played the move
Bishop g5 notice that if you would have
tried to keep the pawn with Bishop f4 he
would have faced the move Knight before
that is really unpleasant
this move is like whoa that's really
what to do now the bishop on C or D 3 is
attacked and everything is attacked you
really have to be careful if you go king
E - I'm gonna take twice from d3 and
then Knight takes here forking the king
and rook that's terrible if you go
Bishop C - I'm gonna go Queen takes d1
or Bishop e2 Queen takes do you want and
now if you go King takes I take here if
you go sorry if you go Bishop takes I'm
gonna go night d3 check for King King
and Bishop disaster like the immediately
disaster this is how sly Marshall was
but ok a yakin was not a baby boy he
knew that that this is not
gonna happen Bishop g5 Bishop e7 trades
and trades now Knight c3 95 probably a
little safer would have been to take
with the other night but anyways it's
not too late after 90 X night to take
with the night he decided to take in
Tudor style with a screen so this is our
starting position we saw the opening
both sides didn't impress and now in
this position of course night bacon if I
would have been more simple he took with
the Queen so preventing right from
counseling and again in this position
you think yourself okay why to move what
would you have done when I'm showing
this position to my students I never
ever get the right plan because well
it's pretty tricky everybody comes up
with the first move this night cannot be
tolerated the night on g4 is a real pain
you know where so the night goes back to
f6 very nice but now what I tell them
okay why to move come up with a plan I
can tell you the plan that I see most
often is casting king h1 and to play f4
etc well I can tell you that by the time
you do that black is not gonna wait for
you he's gonna also can so put a rock on
d8 and get tons of counter play the
black queen can then be chasing to chase
to a the d4 of c-5 then block is just
very much in the game so what to do what
can be done again notice that the black
King hasn't committed itself and now
white is thinking like this well if the
black king sorry
yeah you could know you know pissing
everything if this is gonna be a check
on d4 anyways just talk way to check so
it's just just a transposition not a big
deal
but in this position he thought like
this this I'm going to try to guide you
to the plan he says okay if black is
going to Castle kingside
I have h GF e points like just the
Mongol army just up the board so that's
very appetizing if you go to the Queen
side I better have something ready
it's very unappetizing for black to
Castle kingside because while you're
just gonna go with this pawns up so but
black is gonna play Bishop d7 maybe
Bishop c6 on something in Council long
visual e7 castles so what to do against
it how to play against it watch what he
did he plays Queen d2 okay it first a
little mysterious move some might say
okay maybe he wants to castle long very
nice and true by the way it has to that
part of the plan
so black plays the flexible move Bishop
d7 marshal fully understand the T V
Castle kingside immediately is gonna get
spanked so now he wants to Castle
queenside so on your kid says no now we
understand what's going on the Queen is
centralized f4 is coming anyways and the
pawn on a 7 is being pickled and massage
so casting long Queen takes a 7 game
over at once now Marshall probably was
already a bit uncomfortable because he's
not used to being in a position where
he's the one running around looking for
plants and he played the move Bishop c6
I think probably the move Queen a5 would
have been more challenging that would
have been a more interesting move in
this position but okay we can already
see that white has complete success in
his plan I mean I can play for example
it may be a three before the queen is
not happy to be on the Queen side even
if he cancels so like for example let's
say a three and if you can so long
before and what you're gonna play Queen
b6 already something went a little wrong
for black but probably the last Eva
because when you played Bishop c6
he played castle dong castle already
he's becoming scared because F 4 is
coming anyways so compromised but now
watch how the game plays itself like if
you look at the typical position of
casting on opposite sides as a race and
you say well the White King is still
kind of on c1 closer to the center no
point on c2 and the blocking looks safe
watch pick an etching of this picture of
this position in your mind and compare
it to what happens is just a series of
moves ok f4 that was easy now where to
go to if you try to be aggressive you
lose upon so let's see it Queen to a5 b5
and if 95 the aggressive move simply
takes takes check takes check and Queen
takes d5 going into a beautiful ending
upper porn like really promising ending
with four against two
and of course nothing is going to happen
in the Queen side because my king is
standing there not enough nice so he
went
Queenie six so II 5 naturally and for a
moment the knight doesn't really have to
move but eventually it will so rook f8
route k g1 all the reserves are ready to
play now
rook 88 would have been another possible
rook idiot was played if 97 then g4 I'm
already threatening stuff like Bishop f5
or at the right time f5 and just
horrible position so we can see just by
optically looking that white is just on
the verge of winning so he tries to
bring the last piece into the game
however white continues without relief
f5 Queen e7 Queen g5 look at the
difference nothing happened to the White
King and the series of a bunch of move
the pawns have advanced to f5 and e5
part of it with a gain of time and now
the queen is on g5 of course I'm
threatening to take the knight on f6
there were not denied has to move so 95
the most aggressive response now I'm
sure all of you think that Mike is not
going to treat Queens when he's
attacking f6 well I have one move Queen
f8 I don't feel like getting made it no
do I want to lose my queen so Bishop c4
again this takes a little calculation
because you have to be accurate but it's
already over
after bishops before you can just resign
immediately other moves maybe you could
have played 94 or something like that
but then maybe 94 but he just plays very
accurately here attacking the knight and
controlling a very important diagonal
Knight takes c3 maybe he was hoping for
B takes c3 Queen a3 check also doesn't
look too scary but he is giving him
absolutely no chances rook takes d8
knowing the rook to the other up to d8
roof takes d8 no problem F takes G 7 now
I'm attacking the Queen and the rook on
d8 so the Queen cannot recapture on g7
he tries nightly to check that night is
gone anyways so might as well Sackett
and of course if bishop takes a 2 then I
gain a very important temple Queen c5
check and my rook is gonna move this
completely interferes with White's plan
so simply king b1 now he played Queen to
d8 ok now every move wins Bishop takes
f7 wins for sure he decided to play a
six threat the EF 7 so he played Bishop
before Chuck again trying to mess things
up a little bit why it said nope
needless to say that King takes Knight
Queen a for checkmate would have been
very disappointing here so here
f-five well other variations just for
the record takes takes you gotta take
take you've got to take check losing the
whole house now you lose the bishop on
top and why just wins with a very easy
ending not even a telling him I'll take
with my rook and you're going to lose
everything so you played f-5e seven
check the natural move rook d5 and now
came a move between my opinion was a bit
sadistic of course you can just go rook
takes e4 hard to argue with that and
Bishop takes d5 don't know what he would
have done even after maybe we just
resign but then we are confronted with
the next move he won't resign so he
plays Queen f6 the idea is Queen f8 with
checkmate okay now resigning would have
been good also but you decided to play
one more move Queen f7 again a position
where every move wins you can take on f7
and on e4 you can take on me for on d5
immediately he just did check and
resigns of course after Queen takes
check and mate
a beautiful assault by what if you think
again think of who playing with the
black pieces somebody who's famous for
having games like this is right then
there's really reasons to be impressed
really a masterpiece by yogin even
though the opening was not impressive
the way comes up with a plan in a
simplistic position he comes up with an
imaginary plan how to prevent my
opponent forecasting queenside luring
into the side with all my pawns can
advance and again not exactly the player
would black is not exactly someone it
can be accused of being unconscious knew
exactly what's going to happen but
couldn't really stop it our last example
for the new self camera yeah our last
example for today is this famous game
against e8 this is just a lopsided game
Yates is not playing a great game but
still the guy is one of the strong
master I really maybe i am level maybe
GM level and watch what he does to him
especially the final idea is just
brilliant just so aesthetically
beautiful so we are playing right into a
Queen's Gambit normal line 97 okay
nowadays many other lines are popular
especially 86 Bishop h4 94 the Lasker or
h6 Bishop a4 b6 start to cover very very
common okay this is also a move rook c1
c6 Queen c2 rook e8 again I'm not here
to analyze the opening I black could
have done better than what he does
Bishop d3 okay
takes takes Knight d5 trying to release
from the pin again kind of a standard
maneuver in the Queen's Gambit but watch
what happens in this specific position
94 okay
f5 well very very ambitious probably a
little bit of a knee-jerk reaction
trying to punish White's play I think
this is just not not very good Bishop e7
Queenie 792 now you see that there's a
problem the bishop on c8 well doesn't
have any moves and now e5 is not gonna
be so easy to execute
b5 is these is going to be a nice upon
in some positions not an easy position
to play already I think that black done
basically irreversible damage but it
only gets worse b5 I don't know what he
was thinking about I really don't
understand this move because if the
bishop would have retreated maybe I can
understand but of course he's going to
take obviously because you can take with
the C pawn bet with a pawn because I'll
take on c6 so you must take like this
and now Bishop c8 is really really out
of play and I'm kind of ready on the C
file so bad idea castles a5 now if Black
gets to play the move a four-year maybe
it's gonna have something Knight b6
night c4 maybe he's gonna have something
not a whole lot but white is just in
time here here
BAM then I jump rubbed into c5 and again
I'm trading the pieces already you can
see that if I get to trade nights which
happen in the game I can't believe he
allowed it I would have played any move
but allowed the trade Knight b6 Knight
f6 I don't know I know that worked will
play 95 and have a huge advantage but I
will somehow pray that somehow at some
point maybe I have a chance to do
something as it turned out he played
here here here here thinking that by
relieving some of the material he is
going to have relief but now the c5
combined with the better minor piece but
what how he does it watch how he wins
this game beautifully before unimpressed
doubling Bishop comes out the knight
jumps in maybe black had ideas to play
Bishop c4 here disconnecting the rooks
and attacked in the a pawn then looked
to the C file challenging the rock he
says nope not today
now c4 is super controlled rook b8 f3 no
rush
b3 a 3 yeah whatever part poem he would
push he would push the other just
closing the position there so the route
could just operate freely on the C file
h6 again hard to criticize
the movement there's no hope King F -
King 8 7 H for Rukia fate King g3 just
in case he had ideas to play f4 here so
no he's just marking time he waits to
see what happens
rook c7 Bishop here rook c5 back rook c6
has to go back to the fender pond and
Kia for all the pieces are participating
in this task came back
h5 step by step he's tightening the
screws and black is just dying bishop f1
no gift Bishop back and now just
avoiding the last little drop maybe you
want to double rocks on the seventh rank
so where do you go can go here can go
here can go here can take and it's
either d7i f7 now f7 feels a little
uncomfortable maybe because the night is
holding it but it's the best move if you
play Brooke d7 Bishop b5 skewers you
unpleasantly so Luke f7 King 8 7 may be
the last chance was to play rook f8 but
I'm gonna win the pawn on e6 and not
nice so here to defend the g7 point
after here here now he played 927 ID and
Knight f6 check winning an exchange
because of the pen when the King moves
to h8 still Knight f6 so Yates played
rook f8 okay at first maybe you think
wow he tricked them now you have to
trade drugs and then the knight has to
retreat now he simply took on g7 he took
the night because mate is threatened 187
King e5 resigns why because the route
cannot be defended if you move the rook
back to the only safe Square or
defendant on the only safe Square I'm
going to go check and
so the combination of a meeting thread
and the rook you have to lose material
and of course in this position it just
could do you have a question I'll just
wanted to say king e5 yeah yeah this
position appears a lot by the way in
this position doctor a winning
combination see it in many books takes
takes King e5 very nice okay guys thank
you very much hope you enjoyed the games
of a yoke and I suggest that you will
take a look at this and you call it two
for two volume best games of Alexander
all looking there's tons of great games
here and if you want to get better it's
really a good book to to look at to
analyze thanks again